skyscrapers may define modern urban
skylines but cities existed for
thousands of years before steel frame
structures vaulted mankind upward cities
exist to bring people together and they
have always been shaped by the
transportation and construction
technologies of their errors the
pre-modern city was built for
pedestrians who walked through often
filthy streets and climbed dark
stairwells to fifth-floor Garrett's we
have individual structures like the
Colosseum in the Tower of London that
survived from ancient cities but we have
fewer examples of whole city escapes
that remain as legacies of the past
Pompeii is one such example frozen in
time by the eruption of Vesuvius in 79
ad he provides us with a remarkable
glimpse of urban life in the age of
Imperial Rome the city had once been an
independent ally of Rome but it became
permanently part of the Roman world
after it was occupied by Lucius
Cornelius sulla the Romans built
infrastructure such as spectacular
aqueducts the multitude of fountains
that dot Pompeii testified to the
importance of imported water for daily
urban life the local economy was of
course largely agricultural the rich
volcanic soil nearby produced abundant
grain and good wine but it also had
something of a tourist economy as
wealthy Romans built villas in Pompeii
the city is highly compact and
well-organized with a simple grid
organizing part of the town the
structures are typically short houses
usually have one or two storeys although
sometimes they sit atop ruined older
structures homes will often have an
interior atrium a typical Roman feature
because the Mediterranean climate makes
outdoor living ideal archeologists have
also identified about 100 benches
outside the structures which make it
possible to comfortably wait for
entrance into the home of a powerful
patron rooms are typically quite dark
glass windows seem to have been used by
Romans only after Pompey's destruction
large openings would have exposed homes
both to the elements and to thievery
exquisite paintings both inside and out
bring beauty into these otherwise stock
structures Romans also saw little value
in segregating work in home life
workshops were often inserted into the
ground floor of dwellings craftsmen
would sleep above
enjoy the shortest possible commutes
down a flight of stairs Bruges is a
slightly more modern preserved city it
became frozen in time not by a volcano
but because the silting of the Sven
River in the late 15th century radically
reduced its economic importance
consequently this medieval mega city
became brutally more a dead town
revealing its past whereas Pompeii had
perhaps 11,000 inhabitants at its height
by 1400 Bruges had a population well
over a hundred thousand Bruges as vast
wealth was built on trade in cloth which
had originally been woven from the hairs
of the shaggy sheep who lived nearby
like Venice Bruges is a city of canals
in evil times it was easier to move
goods on water than on land old Bruges
is compact like Pompeii built for
walking and barges homes are taller
often reaching three or four storeys
reflecting abundant demand for the
limited space within the city's walls
brood homes like atria but compensated
with glass windows this older city
required more protection from the
elements including snow and its distinct
Gables are both architectural adornment
and a sensible way to avoid the
accumulation of snowfall as the city
grew richer its wealthier inhabitants
built up and out the grew house which
housed aristocrats is opulent with four
visible rows of windows the house of the
Burroughs family also rises to four
storeys that family began as innkeepers
whose centrally located structure became
a meeting place for finance seers
trading both knowledge and investments
their name which became bourse
now labels stock exchanges throughout
the world four or five stories was
typically the upper limit on pre
elevator housing for who would want to
walk up any higher the nicest floor the
piano nobile a was typically the second
storey enjoying some protection from
sloppy street life but not requiring
much climbing upper floors were cheaper
space providing small Gerrits for the
urban poor such as the artistic
protagonists of La bohème Bruges has an
abundance of public spaces such as its
striking Market Square which is loomed
over by a 270 foot belfry whose bells
would toll out the time in an age before
watches the tower sits atop the massive
cloth hole which is
of a cathedral to trade in wool but
while the merchants of Bruges pointed
forward towards our more secular age the
city's architecture reminds us that even
in that commercial city religion ranked
first the tallest structure in Bruges is
the 400 foot Tower of the church of our
lady indeed church towers with a
dominant feature of most medieval
skylines and many of the great feats of
medieval architecture such as flying
buttresses were aimed at allowing gothic
churches to inspire religious feeling
through sacred space command of glass
brought light and beauty inside urban
Europe is filled with pre-modern
structures that teach us history the
massive palazzi of Florence that
belonged to families such as the Medici
and the struts II remind us both of
their mercantile prosperity and the
dangers of life in 15th century Florence
they are built like fortresses which is
perhaps unsurprising given the
propensity of medieval Florentines to
break out into violence such as the
revolt of the Chompy bruisers buildings
are far less secure suggesting that they
were built in a safer City Paris blasts
Evo's with its elegant four-story
uniformity reminds us of the efforts of
French rulers to impose order on to
urban chaos the curving Gorge and
elegance of Regent Street in London or
the Royal Crescent in Bath reminds us
that uniformity can also come from
private developers attempting to sell
aesthetic grandeur these structures
reflect the wealth of industrializing
England that was poured into growing
consumer cities as London grew richer
and larger the demand for space
propelled buildings upward the Midland
Grand Hotel built at the st. Pancras
station soars to 270 feet elevators made
height easier but the Midland Grande
still has a spectacular central
staircase the structures vast medieval
walls remind us of the difficulty of
building up before steel frames today we
are charmed by pre-modern urban spaces
they are so fundamentally different than
our elevator oriented skyscrapers and
car-based suburbs
yet these pre-modern spaces were still
about enabling mankind to work together
in urban agglomerations older urban
spaces provide a window into the lives
of the past that are both so similar and
so different from our lives today
you